Renteria is showing off his athletic  skills for a good cause 32 year old  royal joined in festivities on the field  in London on Friday he was on hand to  celebrate the expansion of the coach for  apprenticeship program which seeks to  drive young people to become  inspirational sports coaches gary  launched the program in 2012 alongside  his brother Prince William and his  sister-in-law Kate Middleton check out  this shot of Harry chatting with  coaching hopefuls and here looks like we  played a game of cricket Gary also  delivered a speech at the event saying  quote by training the next generation of  coaches to put the child first on the  sport second we hope the ripple effect  of positive experiences and sports are  felt by their participants in their  communities therefore changing lives